No puedo más que con este deseo pensar en cuando eres niño
y tu -- tus amigos te preguntaban si un genio --
te diera un sólo deseo, ¿qué le pedirías?
Y siempre les contestaba, “Yo quisiera que con el deseo supiera--
me gustaría tener la sabiduría para saber exactamente qué pedir."
Pues entonces estarías jodido pues sabrias qué desear
pero ya habrías usado tu deseo.
Y ahora, ya que sólo tenemos un deseo—a diferencia del año pasado cuando tenían tres --
No voy a desear eso.
Hablemos de lo que desearía, que es la paz mundial.
Ya sé qué estarán pensando.
Están pensando, pobre niña --
cree que compite en un concurso de belleza.
Pero no lo está. Está en las charlas del Premio TED.
Pero yo—bueno—a mí me parece que sí tiene sentido,
y creo que la primera etapa en lograr la paz mundial es que la gente se conozca.
He conocido mucha gente diferente con los años
y he filmado a algunas --
desde un ejecutivo de internet de Nueva York que quería conquistar el mundo
hasta un oficial militar de la prensa en Qatar
que preferiría no conquistar el mundo.
Si han visto la película “Control Room” que se estrenó
comprenderían un poco por qué. Gracias.
(Aplausos)
¡Qué bueno! Algunos de ustedes la vieron.
Estupendo. Estupendo.
Asi que, de lo que quisiera hablar hoy
es un medio que permite que la gente viaje,
que se conozca entre sí de manera distinta--
porque no puedes recorrer todo el mundo al mismo tiempo.
Y hace mucho tiempo—bueno, hace unos 40 años,
mi mamá hospedaba a una estudiante de intercambio.
Y les voy a mostrar unas fotos de ella.
Ella es Donna.
Esta es Donna en la Estatua de la Libertad.
Esta es mi madre y tía enseñando a Donna cómo montar en bicicleta.
Esta es Donna comiendo helado.
Y esta es Donna enseñando a mi tía una danza filipina.
Creo de verdad que a medida que el mundo se hace más pequeño,
es cada vez más importante que aprendamos los bailes de los demás,
que nos conozcamos, que nos hagamos íntimos,
que descubramos cómo cruzar fronteras,
para comprendernos, para entender las esperanzas y los sueños de los otros,
para saber qué los hace reír y llorar.
Y no todos podemos participar en programas de intercambio,
y no puedo obligar a todo el mundo a viajar.
De eso ya he hablado con Chris y Amy,
y me dijeron que había un problema con este plan.
No puedes obligar a alguien que tiene libre albedrío, y estoy de acuerdo.
Asi que no vamos a obligar a la gente a viajar.
Pero quiero hablar sobre otra manera de viajar
que no necesita un buque o un avión,
sino unicamente una cámara, un proyector y una pantalla.
Y de eso les voy a hablar hoy.
Me pidieron que les hablara un poco
sobre mis propias raíces,
y Cameron, no sé cómo lograste salvarte de eso,
pero creo que construir puentes es importante para mí
debido a mis raíces.
Soy hija de madre norteamericana
y padre egipcio libanés sirio.
Así que soy el producto de la unión de dos culturas.
Sin ánimo de bromas.
También me han llamado--
como mujer norteamericana egipcia libanesa y siria con apellido persa--
la Crisis de Paz del Medio Oriente.
Así que para mí tal vez tomar fotos fue una manera
de unir ambos lados de mi familia,
una manera de llevar los mundos conmigo, de contar historias visualmente.
En cierta medida empezó así,
pero creo que me di cuenta en serio del poder de la imagen
cuando fui por primera vez al pueblo de los basureros en Egipto.
Cuando tenía unos 16 años, mi madre me llevó allí.
Ella cree firmemente en el servicio comunitario
y decidió que esto era algo que yo necesitaba hacer
así que fui y conocí varias mujeres increíbles ahí.
Había gente que—había un centro allí--
donde enseñaban a la gente a leer y escribir
y vacunarse contra las muchas enfermedades
que puedes contraer por revisar la basura.
Y empecé a enseñar allí.
Enseñaba inglés, y conocí a unas increíbles mujeres allí.
Conocí a gente que vive con siete personas en una sola habitación,
que apenas puede comprar la cena,
no obstante tienen una gran fuerza de voluntad y un gran sentido del humor.
Y tienen cualidades increíbles.
Me atrajo esta comunidad y empecé a tomar fotos allí.
Saqué fotos de bodas y de los miembros mayores de la familias,
de cosas que ellos querían recordar.
Unos dos años después de comenzar a tomar fotografías,
la Conferencia de la ONU sobre Población y Desarrollo
me pidió mostrar las fotos en la conferencia.
Tenía 18 años, estaba muy entusiasmada.
Era mi primera exhibición de fotos y las habían puesto todas,
y dos días después, habían quitado las fotos excepto por tres.
La gente estaba muy ofendida, muy molesta
de que mostrara esos lados sucios de Cairo,
¿y por qué no corté el burro muerto de la foto?
Y mientras me quedaba allí, me deprimí mucho.
Miraba esta gran pared vacía que tenía
tres fotos solitarias, que eran
unas fotos muy bonitas, pero sentí que había fracasado.
Pero veía estas intensas emociones y sentimientos
que había surgido de la gente con sólo ver estas fotos.
Allí estaba yo, una tontita de 18 años a quien nadie escuchaba,
y de repente puse estas fotos en la pared
y hubo discusiones y las tuvieron que quitar.
Y en ese momento vi el poder del imagen.
Y fue increíble.
Y creo que la reacción más importante que vi allí
venía de las personas que nunca habrían ido al pueblo de los basureros,
que nunca habrían visto que el espíritu humano podría florecer
en circunstancias tan difíciles.
Y creo que fue en ese momento que decidí
que quería utilizar la fotografía y la cinematografía
para tender puentes, juntar culturas, juntar gente, cruzar fronteras.
Y eso fue lo que me hizo comenzar.
Hice un trabajo en MTV, un film llamado Startup.com,
y luego como en el 2000 -- Hice un par de filmes musicales --
pero en 2003, cuando la guerra en Irak estaba por comenzar,
Sentí -- fue un sentimiento surreal para mi
porque antes de comenzar la guerra, había esta guerra mediática.
Y estaba mirando la tele en Nueva York
y parecía haber un único punto de vista
que se proyectaba, e iba de--
la cobertura iba del Departamento de Estado de EEUU a las tropas estacionadas
y lo que la gente -- lo que proyectaban las noticias
era que habría una guerra limpia y bombardeos de precisión,
y los iraquíes aclamarían a los norteamericanos como libertadores
lanzando flores a sus pies en las calles de Baghdad.
Y yo sabía que había una historia completamente distinta
ocurriendo en el Medio Oriente donde estaban mis padres.
Yo sabía que allí se contaba una historia totalmente diferente,
y yo pensaba ¿cómo se va a comunicar la gente
entre sí cuando reciben mensajes totalmente distintos
y nadie sabe nada de lo que se dice al otro lado?
¿Cómo se va a llegar a una comprensión común
para saber cómo avanzar al futuro?
Así que supe que tenía que ir ahí.
Sólo quería estar en el centro.
No tenía planes, no tenía fondos.
En ese momento ni siquiera tenía una cámara.
Le pedí a alguien que me la llevara
porque quería tener acceso a Al Jazeera,
el canal favorito de George Bush
y un lugar sobre el cual tenía mucha curiosidad porque
es despreciado por muchos gobiernos del mundo árabe
y también lo llaman el portavoz de Osama Bin Laden
algunas personas en el gobierno estadounidense.
Así que yo pensaba, esta estación que es odiada
por tanta gente debe estar haciendo algo bien.
Tengo que investigarlo.
También quería visitar Central Command,
que quedaba a 10 minutos de distancia, y así
podría acceder a ver cómo se creaban las noticias
desde el lado árabe para el mundo árabe,
y desde el lado occidental para los EEUU.
Y cuando fui y me senté allí,
y conocí a estas personas que estaban en el centro de todo
y me senté con estos personajes,
conocí algunas personas sorprendentes, muy complejas.
Y me gustaría compartir con ustedes un poco de esa experiencia
de sentarte con una persona y filmarla, y escucharla,
y permitirles más que un segmento de cinco segundos,
y ver la asombrosa complejidad que surge.
Sameer Khader: Sin novedades.
Irak. He estado en Irak.
Pero entre tú y yo, si Fox me ofrece trabajo, lo aceptaré.
Transformar la pesadilla árabe en el sueño americano.
Todavía sueño con esto.
Quizá nunca se cumpla.
Pero tengo planes para mis hijos.
Cuando terminen la secundaria los mandaré a América a estudiar.
Les pagaré los estudios.
Y se quedarán allí.
Josh Rushing: la noche que mostraron los prisioneros de guerra y los soldados muertos --
Al Jazeera los mostró --
fue muy impactante porque en América no se muestran este tipo de imágenes.
La mayoría de las noticias norteamericanas no muestran imágenes muy sangrientas
y esto mostraba soldados norteamericanos uniformados esparcidos por el suelo,
un frío piso de losa.
Y era repugnante.
Era absolutamente repugnante.
Me hizo sentir mal del estómago.
Y lo que me impactó fue que, la noche anterior,
hubo un bombardeo en Basra,
y Al Jazeera mostró imágenes de la gente.
Eran igual de horrorosas, si no más que éstas.
Y recuerdo haberlas visto en la oficina de Al Jazeera
y pensé, “¡Ay, qué asqueroso!
¡Qué terrible!"
Y luego me fui, y cené o hice cualquier cosa.
Y no me impactó tanto.
Entonces -- el impacto de darme cuenta de que
acababa de ver la gente del otro lado,
y esa gente de la oficina de Al Jazeera
se sentía como yo me sentí aquella noche.
Me afectó a un nivel profundo
que no me molestara tanto la noche anterior.
Me hace odiar la guerra.
Pero no me hace creer que estemos en un mundo que pueda vivir sin guerra aún.
Jehane Noujaim: Me abrumó la respuesta a la película,
porque no sabíamos si podríamos lanzarla.
No teníamos fondos para la película.
Tuvimos mucha suerte de que fuera seleccionada,
y cuando la mostramos, tanto en los Estados Unidos como en el mundo árabe
recibimos unas reacciones increíbles.
Fue asombroso ver cómo esta película impactó a la gente.
En el mundo árabe—en realidad no era la película lo que los impactó,
sino los personajes.
Es decir, Josh Rushing era un personaje increíblemente complejo
que reflexionaba sobre muchas cosas.
Y cuando mostré el film en el Medio Oriente
la gente decía- la gente quería conocer a Josh.
En cierta medida nos redefinió como población americana.
Él—la gente empezaba a preguntarme, ¿dónde está ese tipo ahora?
Al Jazeera le ofreció un empleo.
Y Sameer, por otro lado,
también era un personaje interesante para el mundo árabe,
porque afloró la complejidad de esta relación amor / odio
que el mundo árabe tiene con Occidente.
En los Estados Unidos, me asombraron las motivaciones,
las motivaciones positivas del pueblo norteamericano
al ver esta película.
En el extranjero nos critican por sentirnos --
por creernos los salvadores del mundo de alguna manera,
pero al otro lado en realidad,
cuando la gente ve lo que está pasando en el extranjero,
y las reacciones de la gente a nuestra política exterior,
sentimos que necesitamos --
sentimos que tenemos que tomar el poder para cambiar las cosas.
Y vi este fenómeno en las audiencias.
Una mujer se me acercó luego de una proyección y dijo "¿Sabes?
Sé que es difícil de creer, vi cómo cargaban las bombas en los aviones,
vi las tropas ir a la guerra.
Pero uno no entiende la rabia de la gente hacia nosotros
hasta que ves la gente en los hospitales y las víctimas de la guerra,
y ¿cómo salimos de esta burbuja?
¿Cómo comprendemos lo que está pensando la otra persona?"
Ahora, no sé si una película puede cambiar el mundo,
pero sí sé que comienza -- conozco el poder que--
Sé que hace que la gente comience a pensar en cómo cambiar el mundo.
No soy una filósofa,
así que siento que no debo profundizar mucho en esto, sino mostrarles --
permitir que el cine hable por sí mismo y los lleve a este otro mundo.
Porque creo que el cine es capaz de hacerte cruzar fronteras.
Me gustaría que se relajen para experimentar durante algunos minutos
lo que es ser llevado a otro mundo.
Y estos dos fragmentos te llevan adentro
de dos de los conflictos más difíciles con los que nos enfrentamos hoy día.
Hombre 1: Siempre que haya injusticia, ¡alguien debe sacrificarse!
Mujer 1: Eso no es sacrificio, ¡es venganza!
Si matas, no hay diferencia entre la víctima y el ocupante.
Hombre 1: Si tuviéramos aviones, no necesitaríamos mártires, esa es la diferencia.
Mujer: La diferencia es que el ejército israelí sigue siendo más fuerte.
Hombre: Si es así, que seamos iguales en la muerte.
Todavía tenemos el Paraíso.
Mujer: ¡No hay Paraíso! ¡Sólo existe en tu imaginación!
Hombre: Ojalá que no. ¡Ojalá que no!
Que Dios te perdone.
Si tú no fueras la hija de Abu Azzam...
De cualquier forma, ¡preferiría tener el Paraíso en mi cabeza que vivir en este infierno!
En esta vida, estamos muertos de todas formas.
Hombre: Uno sólo escoge la amargura cuando la alternativa es aun más amarga.
Mujer: ¿Y qué pasa con nosotros? ¿Los que se quedan?
¿Ganaremos de esa manera?
¿No ves que lo que haces nos está destruyendo?
¿Y que das a Israel una excusa para continuar?
Man: Así que sin una excusa, ¿Israel parará?
Mujer: Tal vez. Tenemos que convertirla en una guerra moral.
Hombre. ¿Cómo hacerlo si Israel no tiene moral?
Mujer: ¡Ten cuidado!
George: Mi esposa Ayelet me llamó y me dijo
"Hubo un atentado suicida en Tel Aviv."
Ayelet: ¿Qué sabe usted de las víctimas?
Estamos buscando tres chicas.
George: No tenemos informaciones.
Ayelet: Una está herida aquí, pero no tenemos noticias de las demás.
George: Dije, "Bueno, es Bat-Chen, es mi hija."
“¿Están seguros de que está muerta?"
Me dijeron que sí.
Ese día, a eso de las seis y media
estaba conduciendo con mi esposa y mis hijas al supermercado.
Cuando llegamos aquí...
vimos tres jeeps del ejército israelí estacionados al lado del camino.
Cuando pasamos el primer jeep...
nos abrieron fuego.
Y mi hija de 12 años Christine
quedó muerta en el tiroteo.
Tzvika: Soy el director del colegio.
George: Pero ¿hay un professor que esté encargado?
Tzvika: Sí, tengo asistentes.
Trabajo con niños todo el tiempo.
Tzvika: Al principio me pareció una idea extraña
Pero después de pensarlo lógicamente,
No me pareció mala idea conocerlos
y hacerles saber de nuestro padecimiento.
George: Hubo muchas cosas que me impactaron.
Vemos que hay palestinos que sufrieron mucho, que perdieron sus hijos,
pero que siguen creyendo en el proceso de paz y reconciliación.
Si nosotros que perdimos lo que más queremos podemos conversar,
y anticipar un mejor futuro,
entonces todo el mundo debe hacerlo, también.
Hombre: La canción es algo que utilizamos para comunicar con personas
que de otra forma no sabrían de dónde venimos.
Tú podrías darles un largo discurso político
y todavía no comprenderían.
Pero te juro, cuando terminas la canción,
la gente dirá, “Carajo, entiendo a ustedes los negros.
Los entiendo.
¡Muerte al apartheid!"
Narrador: Se trata de la lucha por la libertad...
Es sobre esos niños que salieron a las calles,
luchando, gritando, “¡Liberen a Nelson Mandela!"
Es sobre los sindicatos que abandonaron sus herramientas
y exigieron la libertad.
Sí. ¡Sí!
¡La libertad!
Jehane Noujaim: Creo que todo el mundo ha tenido la experiencia de sentarse en un cine,
en un cuarto oscuro con otros desconocidos, mirando una película muy impactante,
y tuvieron esa sensación de transformación.
Y estoy hablando de--
lo que quisiera discutir es ¿cómo podemos usar esa sensación
para crear un movimiento a través del cine?
He estado escuchando las charlas
de la conferencia, y Robert Wright dijo ayer
que si apreciamos la humanidad de otra persona,
esa persona apreciará también la nuestra.
Y de eso se trata.
Se trata de unir a la gente a través de la cinematografía,
de propagar estas voces independientes.
Josh Rushing terminó dejando el ejército
y aceptando un empleo con Al Jazeera,
siente que está en Al Jazeera International porque
siente que puede realmente utilizar los medios
para tender puentes entre Oriente y Occidente.
Y es algo asombroso.
Pero he intentado pensar en maneras
de apoderar a esas voces independientes,
de apoderar a los cineastas,
de apoderar a gente que quiere usar el cine para el cambio.
Y existen organismos increíbles
que ya lo están haciendo.
Existe Witness, de la que ya han escuchado.
Existe Just Vision, que trabaja con palestinos e israelís
que colaboran por la paz, y documentan el proceso
y entrevistan a varias personas y usan el cine
para llevarlo al Congreso y mostrar que es una herramienta potente,
para mostrar que ésta es una mujer cuya hija fue matada en un ataque,
y ella cree que hay maneras pacíficas de resolver el conflicto.
Existe Working Films y existe Current TV,
que es una plataforma increíble para que gente alrededor del mundo
pueda poner sus-- sí, es increíble.
Lo vi y me-- me asombra el organismo
y su potencial para unir voces alrededor del mundo,
voces independientes de alrededor del mundo,
y crear una televisión realmente democrática y global.
¿Qué podemos hacer para crear una plataforma para estos organismos,
para que adquieran velocidad,
para involucrar a todo el mundo en este movimiento?
Quiero que imaginemos por un segundo -- imaginen un día
en que todo el mundo se una.
Tienes pueblos y ciudades y teatros alrededor del mundo
unidos, sentados en la oscuridad,
compartiendo la experiencia comunal de ver una película,
o un par de películas, juntos.
Viendo una película que tal vez resalta
un personaje que lucha por vivir, o simplemente
un personaje que desafía los estereotipos,
cuenta un chiste, canta una canción.
Comedias, documentales, cortometrajes.
Este poder asombroso se puede usar para cambiar a la gente
y para unirla, para cruzar fronteras
y hacer que la gente sienta que tiene una experiencia comunal.
Si imaginan este día en que alrededor del mundo
hay teatros en todo el mundo y lugares donde se proyectan películas.
Si imaginan desde --
proyectar desde Times Square hasta Tahir Square en Cairo,
la misma película en Ramallah, la misma película en Jerusalén.
Incluso podríamos usar -- hemos estado hablando con un amigo
sobre usar un lado de la Gran Pirámide
y La Gran Muralla China.
Hay-- La imaginación es infinita,
en cuanto a lugares donde proyectar películas
y donde tener esta experiencia comunal.
Y creo que este día, si podemos crearlo,
este día podría popularizar estas voces independientes.
No existe un lugar--
ni un organismo que esté conectando
las voces independientes del mundo para que se popularicen,
y sin embargo escucho a lo largo de esta conferencia
que el peligro más grande en nuestro futuro será comprender el otro
y tener respeto mutuo por el otro y cruzar fronteras.
Y si el cine es capaz de hacerlo,
y si podemos lograr que estas diferentes localidades del mundo
vean juntos estas películas, podría ser un día increíble.
Bueno, ya hemos establecido una relación mediante el proyecto TED--
alguien de la comunidad TED,
John Camen, me presentó a
Steven Apkon, del Jacob Burns Film Center.
Y empezamos a llamar a todo el mundo.
Y esta última semana, ha habido tanta gente que ha respondido
desde Palo Alto hasta Mongolia y la India.
Hay gente que quiere participar en este día global del cine,
para poder ofrecer un espacio para que las voces independientes
y las películas independientes se popularicen.
Hemos pensado en un nombre para este día
y me gustaría compartir esto con ustedes.
La parte más increíble de este proceso
ha sido compartir ideas y deseos,
así que los invito a formar tormentas de ideas sobre --
¿cómo sera ese día en el futuro?
¿Cómo usamos la tecnología para que este día impacte el futuro,
para que podamos construir comunidad
y tener estas comunidades colaborando a través del Internet?
Hubo un día—hubo una época, hace muchísimos años,
cuando todos los continentes estaban juntos.
Y a esa masa le llamamos Pangea.
Así que quisieramos llamar este día como el Día Pangea del Cine.
Y si se imaginan,
que toda la gente de los pueblos del mundo serían espectadores,
entonces creo que realmente podemos crear un movimiento
para que la gente se entienda mejor entre sí.
Sé que es muy intangible, tocar los corazones y almas de la gente,
pero la única forma que sé cómo hacerlo,
la única forma que conozco cómo alcanzar
el corazón de alguien alrededor del mundo es mostrándole una película.
Y sé que hay cineastas y películas independientes allá afuera
que pueden lograr esto realmente.
Y ése es mi deseo.
Supongo que debería expresarles mi deseo en una sola frase.
pero ya se me acabó el tiempo.
Chris Anderson: Es un deseo increíble.
El Día Pangea del Cine — el día en que se une el mundo entero.
JN: Es más tangible que la paz mundial, y seguro que es más inmediato.
Pero sería el dia en que el mundo se una a través del cine,
el poder del cine.
CA: Damas y caballeros, Jehane Noujaim.